[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting our AUSA's
ourselves that's right just the two of
us yeah this is a very very special your
biscuits this is don't know if we gave
you much warning but this is the season
two ear biscuits finale grand finale we
I'm excited about this conversation
don't know how long it's gonna go I
think a lot of things are gonna surface
here amongst us and for you there's it
so there's a there's an interesting take
on this thing but yeah we before we get
into uh say yeah we're taking a break
from ear biscuits in order to focus on
some other creative endeavors and trust
me it's gonna be worth it oh yes we we
have every intention to develop more
entertaining things for not only your
ears but your eyes and your eyes and
your ears together and your souls so you
know with good mythical morning continue
to to roll along we needed to create a
buffer creative buffer to focus on
perhaps some narrative content why say
that link I said so enjoy this grand
finale of season two of your biscuits
hang in with us now that this the
concept for this ear biscuit was not not
only not our idea but but it was a
surprise was that it was happening this
was a Stevie this a child as far as I
can tell this was Stevie's idea to have
previous guests of ear biscuits come on
and grill us with some questions because
we've been asking a lot of questions to
a lot of people over the past two
seasons of ear biscuits so you heard it
right here this is going to be all
questions from previous ear biscuits
guests for us and I have the audio
recordings of their questions so it's as
if they're they walk into the room sit
down at the round table of dim lighting
ask their question and then politely
excuse themselves while while we answer
the question and the
just to clarify we do not have all of
these people here silently waiting to
ask the question that would it be weird
it's very difficult to get that many
people into the same place at the same
time I mean sometimes they do it for
like those weird like promos you know
like for the WB and they're like [ __ ]
back in like 1993
they'd like to have like Steve Harvey
and some other people all together in
one place like in the commercial break
that's not the kind of thing that's
happening tonight it's going to be
recordings yeah and I've got them here
on my computer so I'll just play them
and we can listen to them then we can
answer the question are you ready to get
started it's like we're being grilled
here and you know it basically everyone
who submitted an audio question we're
gonna answer you know it's we're gonna
give them a turn um but yeah I guess we
should get started here so let's start
with why wait I hope you can hear me
okay I'm in a strip mall in kamon Iowa
this is nice Peter and I'd like to know
honestly how much time each of you spend
on your beautiful hair on an average day
okay okay bye okay that's nice Peter
plus a good one get started yeah epic
Rap Battles of History on on tour in the
Des Moines Iowa I guess so this is the
question he wanted he wanted to ask us
how much how much time do you spend on
your beautiful hair on an average day
well I will start by saying that we did
do a whole sponsored series about how I
could style my hair in seconds that's
true that is not actually how I do it
I mean I don't do it in seconds but I do
believe it takes minutes that it it is
definitely minutes I I'm gonna give my
honest assessment is get out of the
shower so I start with the wet hair I
put some product in I blow dry while the
product is in and then I reapply more
product you so it'll be kind of dry you
blow dry your hair I have to because if
I don't it I'll look like my hair is wet
we've given the product that I put in my
hair I don't recall ever
in all the years we shared a hotel room
you get the blowing the blow drying of
my hair is a last 24 to 36 months
phenomenon and you can see a definitive
difference in the way my hair looked
like we were shooting commercial Kings
like I was actually we were watching an
old clip today like it was kind of like
wet looking all the time yeah my hair
isn't wet looking anymore because of
that but the total time honestly you
have to check a bit of pride at the door
when you pull out it blowed oh yeah in
fact my wife and I just moved into a new
place and we have a bathroom that
actually has drawers this is in two
sinks the first time we've ever had two
sinks in there you've arrived there is a
drawer in between the two sinks that
sort of equi distant from each sink and
I put the hairdryer in there because I
was like baby we both use it equally oh
you don't have a Rhett dryer and again
be talking about getting one out because
hers is purple with a purse
you mean our our hair dryer is purple I
need like a black hair dryer with like
silver trim anyway superheat it like it
needs to hurt you when it blow dries
your hair so you like feel manly but you
know I just sear your forehead
well I check my pride at the door but my
hair you you all know that I I don't
enjoy having this hair it's I'm kind of
a victim of my hair at this point but
total time seven minutes okay for me
it's 90 seconds but I'm thinking maybe I
should blow-dry cuz my hair looks wet
all the time and there's no way it takes
90 I've seen you get on your forehead
and the hair that's on the forehead I've
seen you wiggle that hair around for 90
seconds there's no way that the whole
process takes 90 seconds I'll time it
after this nice piece thanks for my I'm
a great estimator of time I say seven
minutes a day gosh alright so I no more
than two and a half minutes it's wet I
dry it with a towel I spray the spray on
it and then I fix it with my hands okay
and that's it and I think silently to
myself about how I'm glad I'm not using
a blow-dryer
and how awesome then well maybe you
should hide you just write your towel
dry your hair that's what you do tell ya
why I do that but then I blow dry let's
let's take another question now I guys
these they get they get deeper we do
that stuff but I just thought that was a
fun one to start with
here is a second one hey rhettandlink
this is colleen ballinger and i have a
question for you I was wondering what
your most embarrassing moment is I need
to know we've talked about our
embarrassing moments well that's the
difficult thing with having been on the
internet for so long and told so many
personal stories that we've answered
this question on good mythical morning
in an episode each called links most
embarrassing moment that was yours and
then mine is called rets most
embarrassing well it was actually good
morning chillin yeah good morning Sheila
can clean GMM it's funny because I
watched it back to make sure I that I
still think is my most embarrassing
moment and I haven't topped it since
telling that story so yeah you know I'll
recap the same one do you yeah do you
have a newer embarrassing moment story
or you know well okay well just recap
mine is also not as embarrassing as
yours so let me start with know yeah I
mean mine which I will tell the
truncated version of right now is when
we were on vacation a not vacation we're
traveling and our families were in
Kentucky together and we had our kids at
the time I think we had two total kids
between the two families so we were all
in one van that we were renting we took
a break went into a gas station I went
to the bathroom then I came back out and
started to get into the van you were
driving the van at a time and you had
locked the door so I began to pull on
the door and thinking that you're
playing a prank on me and won't let me
get in the door or didn't realize that I
was trying to get in the door I said
open the door
can't really see into the car because it
was tinted windows and it was there was
kind of a reflection and I said open the
door and I started to yell because I was
I wasn't in the mood to play around or
to joke around at the time as I'm
getting louder and louder and yelling
open the door now I look through
a window and finally the person on the
other side of that window in the passage
on the driver's side across the car
comes into focus and it is a woman with
her children and she sees this large man
but demanding to get into her car and
the look on her face was I am going to
die today and that was when I realized
wrong van same color same model wrong
van perfect stranger your van that you
were actually driving that I was
supposed to be riding him was just like
two vans down I don't really I wish I
would actual van been able to look over
and see that happen I don't remember
that I must have been looking the other
way or something oh man that was pretty
embarrassing but there wasn't like a
debrief conversation with the woman like
roll you wet it down roll your window
down so I could tell you know I didn't
find why I was gelling at you didn't
follow up didn't follow up I didn't
follow up with what happened with my
either in college there was a summer
where me and Matt Newkirk got into
working out and if you really get into
working out in college you work out and
then we would actually swim in the pool
as like as part of like a cool down and
then we would you'd go into the locker
room you take a shower yeah and you know
we're you know we're adults here this is
college you know let's not be too
sheepish here you just get buck naked
and you take a shower right this is not
a big deal don't worry buddy does it
everybody does it but I wasn't that
comfortable with it so the moment I got
out of shower I was like putting a towel
around and everything and like walking
back over to where the lockers were so I
could put my clothes back on and I had
this system where I would strategically
at the last second take the towel off
bend over put on my underwear and put on
my shorts really quick because I just
didn't like being naked with all these
guys walking around in the locker room I
just wasn't comfortable doing that yeah
normal but so I was doing my system and
this isn't good morning chillin and when
we when we came up with the phrase the
moment of nay
kidness must be minimized right because
of my system
well I drop my towel and as I bend over
to get my underwear and put them on I
feel the sensation of my butt cheeks
being pressed against something I was
like there's no wall here behind me and
then I start to realize that it's like a
cold clammy thing that I'm pushing up
against like a whale and then I turned
often but tirana look and there is a
large shirtless man sitting on a bench
right behind me and I have planted my
butt cheeks square into the dudes back
like smush - man professor
nono was a professor yeah and it was
just it was one of those horrifying
embarrassing moments where time slows
down to a crawl and you know it took it
just felt like it took a minute to like
pry my butt cheeks off of this guy's it
probably didn't back and did you speak
to him I was looking and then he turned
and our eyes met and then I just we rise
met right after your butt in his back
man yeah I've whipped my head back
around really quick pulled up my
underwear pulled up my pants gathered on
myself and ran around the corner to the
other lockers and like you ran away
coward yeah just an embarrassment I'm
the right thing put on all my clothes
and then as I walk out I like see the
guy yeah like you gave him a nod I'm not
it and that was me um nice to get to
know you
that was that was so embarrassing I mean
but he had the grace not to say anything
or not to get up he wasn't public
embarrassment which is what neither one
of those quite those experiences were
really big public embarrassment so I'm
grateful for that
all right there's there's actually a
second half to Coleen's question here
let's play that you know it's me Miranda
and I have a really good quaint Jean for
you I was wondering who is your favorite
youtuber and you better see me or else
I'll be willing to dolls
and was also wondering what is your
favorite kind of jeans I just wanted to
know because I'm trying out new
different kinds of gym since I'm a new
juice connoisseur that wasn't us that
burped I just want to clarify that was
as marina that was Miranda who burped
and then breathed it on the other side
of it who's your favorite youtuber okay
Miranda Isles
I'll say Oh easily you're my favorite
youtuber I would say besides Miranda in
an effort to not alienate any any actual
youtubers I carry friends only I'm gonna
say I'm gonna go with a channel that I
believe is my favorite channel okay and
that's bad lip reading you're gonna say
that I only have to agree it's it I
never am disappointed in a video on that
channel
you know I it's so much work I know that
they can't do they can only do so many
but there's very few YouTube channels
that I'm just like is there there's a
new video there I am guaranteed without
fail to be entertained at a at the
highest level I don't have Lippert I
don't put off watching it I was like I
haven't watched any to Twilight stuff
and I was like it almost made me want to
watch the Twilight movies after watching
it's better to just watch the bad lip
products so yeah I'm gonna go with that
what about juice well my favorite kind
of juice I don't know if this counts but
we've got this refrigerator in our
office that like a secret for our own
fridge in our office and we have stocked
that thing with some kombucha this is a
this is very Southern California I'm
just gonna go ahead and admit that yeah
we've got some kombu to in there that's
like a firm minute tea but there's a
specific type of kombucha that has chia
seeds this is like double-double
Southern California so just you know
excuse that but it it's chock full of
chia seeds Chia juice man I not juicing
the Chia I mean it's juice as chia
kombucha which is not technically a
juice but it is in the juice family and
it is my favorite juice and I love that
stuff I love it too if you look at
secret fridge that's the only thing in
there well there's some of that yerba
mate a stuff that's good too nice Peter
actually introduced us to that on the
set of ER B but the the kombucha was
something our wives got us into and then
I discovered the Chia because I was
putting the Chia in the smoothies and
then I realized there was the Chia
inside of the kombucha and now we only
do Chia kombucha exclusively and Chia
gets like it has that snotty casual
sadness like it's great love that fifty
percent of your daily and your daily
requirement of fiber in a drink in a G's
well you know I need that I wonder what
Miranda's favorite jeans what she's
asking us what she needs to be drinking
that's it
all right let's tee up Grace's question
here the only double guess so far on
your biscuits
hello Britain link this is grace and how
big the first here is my question for
you guys I think one of the hardest but
most beneficial things that we can do as
human beings is reflect on times that
we've felt like failures I would be very
curious to know at what time or times in
each of your lives you felt like a
failure and why and how that has maybe
helped shape the people that you are or
giving you some sort of perspective so
on and so forth okay that's it yep that
yep yep yeah that's it that's it okay
okay bye right bye
oh she's so she's uh she's going for the
jugular well I mean she's getting a
little more personal a little more
personal failures failures hmm you want
to go on we've never failed no I think
it's uh I think the difficulty is
thinking about which thing to talk about
because that we've there's a lot of
things that we that we've done
individually and collectively that
haven't turned out the way that we would
have liked them to I I think there was a
definitive moment that comes to my mind
with commercial Kings
the TV show that we had on IFC when it
wasn't renewed so they ordered ten
episodes
and we made all of them it wasn't like
all I nation where it was like we were
hired to host some show and then it was
like cancelled the show wasn't cancelled
but so it wasn't really a failure in
that sense but then they had to make a
decision to renew it or not and so
everything was focused on one particular
decision and an answer like a yes or a
no this is coming back and it actually
took a long time after season one ended
they kind of they didn't make a decision
they kind of strung it out there for
months for months but then there was a
point where the answer finally was no
you know it was was that an email or a
phone call I think it was strung out so
far that it actually just turned out to
be an email I honestly can't remember
the specific moment but I think whether
it was an email phone I think there was
a time in which we were like well if it
was gonna get renewed we would already
know well that's what we told ourselves
but I mean I think it that was a
different because there was a definitive
answer and it came it did feel like a
failure I mean now well it definitely
feel like a failure because it was like
okay you know it's interesting we've
never we've never told anybody this but
you know I don't know if you were we
were together at the time I'm pretty
sure what was it what was it joke Pinhas
wedding that raywilliamjohnson was at
where was it that this is the first time
we ever met raywilliamjohnson back in
the day and he came out to us and we
just moved out here to make commercial
Kings and he was basically said like
we're all we're all counting on you to
for this thing to be a success like you
guys are gonna be the first people to
show that I remember the new tubers can
cross over or whatever you know it was
the first interaction I ever had with a
guy but you know but so there was this
sense of alright this has got to work
because people are watching and just
because we're mean that's added pressure
but I mean there's just the fact that
hey we're dropping everything we're
moving to another coast this is what
we're doing this is gonna be our life
right now
and we're dragging our families out here
and we're making it well not dragging
them but we're moving our families out
here we're making this thing he came
willingly and it it's um
when it when there's that point of the
answer's no yeah it felt like a failure
and now in retrospect certainly I mean
after that is when we in the after
matter that we had to figure out what
we're gonna do we started good mythical
morning I mean I'm very very thankful
that it happened the way that it
happened but I don't want to gloss over
the fact that there was that there was
more than a moment where it yeah it just
felt like well that that was a big thing
we put everything into that it didn't
work now what are we gonna do and we the
answer was we're gonna rebuild our
YouTube channel and we're but by the way
we're also gonna write a TV pilot we're
gonna start having meetings for
television something that we never
talked about because it never amounted
to anything yeah I'm not calling that a
failure but you should it didn't that
didn't work out either but it's that
it's it's those conversations that you
have to have when you have to tell
everybody you have to tell your friends
you have to tell your fans you have to
tell your audience you have to tell your
family members you have to tell your mom
yeah the show they didn't order it again
and so I developed this speech that I
would say and you know what there's
still times that I say it now I say it
all the time I mean so you know what I'm
what I'm about to say what's this what's
the speech well I I mean the explanation
right well I well I'm just saying the
fact that the show got cancelled it's
always how I explain why we live out
here because people are like what
brought you to LA and I'm like well I
make Internet videos and then one of the
things I was doing on the internet got
turned into a television show
I got cancelled after one season but you
know but now I'm doing the internet
thing full time and it's great so it's
like and there's actually a failure
built into the story of why I live here
and I'll even throw in things and early
on it was there more it was kind of like
taking the edge off the fact that it
didn't work which was all true which was
well you know IFC was they were trying
to figure out if they wanted to do they
wanted to get in a more narrative and
our show wasn't here they said it was
good we were very proud of it it was
great experience but
they wanted to do other things on their
channel so they made the decision not to
order more of them you know so it you
kind of give the explanation take the
edge off
it wasn't us it was them but the fact
but the fact is is that you know this
many years later looking at it I think
we both know how we would do things
differently and I'm not saying it would
have by any means guaranteed that the
show would have continued and I think
we're all on the same page that
ultimately it's been great that it
wasn't we didn't get picked up we here
we wouldn't be here right now without it
so to graces question how has that
experience shaped us as people do you
think I mean I I think I go into
everything that we do with a with the
with an overwhelming sense there's
absolutely no guarantee that it's going
to be a success but more and more with
every year that passes with a I'm
compelled to trust us before we trust
anybody else's voice you know because I
think that a lot of the things that we
would change about commercial Kings are
things that we we just sit and feel
confident enough to to say or to
implement you know even though we
probably had that had the ability to as
executive producers of the show I don't
think it would've like Rijn made it have
a second I don't think it would have
made it have a second season but it
there's just this like you know what
there's no guarantees that anything is
going to work and the best chance that
you can give it is by trusting yourself
and doing everything you can to execute
your vision so I kind of approach every
single thing that we do and I also
approach everything with a if this
doesn't work I've learned that it's
always a step to something else
so I can't get too torn up if something
doesn't work yeah because we moved on to
things which I'm so thankful that
they're better for us and we're enjoying
ourselves and it's almost happened every
sing every single time yeah with online
nation and with you know there's there's
lots of time every failure has opened
the door to something that we've
actually wanted more than the thing that
we were trying to succeed at I mean I
think on a much more microscopic scale
I'm sure you'd agree with this I don't
maybe
making this overdramatic but just in
terms of feeling like a failure it's
easy to feel like a failure as a father
or a husband sometimes I think that
those are the things that happen
I'm a perfect father more often because
you got when you have kids you'd you
know it's uh it's it's a demanding thing
to have to have patience and I don't
have a lot of that for younger human
beings and like I gotta apologize a good
amount to my children which i think is a
healthy thing you know I think they
that's my spin at least hey as long as
you I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry father but
I don't I don't want to just dive too
deep into into all the failures we
should just move on okay yeah unless you
want to talk about some more failures
now let's move on to a question from
mamrie Hart
good question grace here we go with the
main town my first question is being a
fellow North Carolinian sometimes I
think how easy it would be to go back to
North Carolina and be able to make
youtube videos from there what you guys
could do so what is it that keeps you in
Los Angeles rather than doing what y'all
do back in the Tar Heel State yes I did
say Tar Heel I know you guys did not go
to Carolina and my second question is
something I always asked people which is
what's the first inanimate object you
ever dry hump here haha she always asks
people that she's never asked me that I
can believe that she sounds like she's
on a phonograph like that when we're
playing a record or like when Southland
you know we were able to first translate
human sounds into instruments you know
like one of those big horn 78 or
whatever that like a record player with
a big horn on it okay I think it's
called a phonograph I don't know maybe
I'm just making things up do we think
about going back to North Carolina and
in doing this we could do this from
North Carolina it seems like that's what
she thinks sometimes so I think there's
there's
number of parts of this I think number
one a number one we love Los Angeles so
there's a lot of people who hate Los
Angeles I recognize that and they're
like homesick I think something about
our personalities wanting to kind of be
in the middle of things we haven't grown
tired of Los Angeles yet mm-hmm so we
like it here so that that's just kind of
to start off with well and I don't mean
to say anything about the weather which
is hackneyed but I will say that I've
never used that word since I'm learning
it in vocabulary I don't even see me
great and I probably misused I thought
it was like when something's wrong with
your knee I'm at need but it's it's 74
degrees outside right now like 9:30 at
night
and it's probably that cool in here and
because we're not outside and I'm
wearing a t-shirt a hoodie a jacket and
a hat and I thought about putting a
hoodie over my head I mean yeah yeah but
that we've changed that being said you
know I just went back to North Carolina
and visited family and it was great and
I'm I miss all of them and it's tough to
be away from family and friends back
home but I love being here I just love
being in a place where them so many
people are trying to do it there they're
doing artistic stuff or they're related
in this business in some way you never
have to explain and you know I it's not
that people who are trying to do
interesting and artistic stuff are not
elsewhere are not in North Carolina no
there's a lot of people doing
interesting artistic stuff in North
Carolina yeah but there's something
about a place like New York City or a
place like Los Angeles where people who
are treating as high and as far as they
possibly can in the arts migrated to
these places not exclusively but most or
at least many of them do kind of migrate
to these areas and what that ends up
creating is just a really interesting
community of people that not only can
you interact with just on a personal
level but I think I'm gonna take issue
with what she said I think it would be
easy to go back and make
the videos that were doing in north
night I don't think it would be easy
because you know what Stevie
is from North Carolina and what did she
do she moved to Los Angeles and we hired
her when she was out here in Los Angeles
yeah as an example everyone on your team
you know I'm I love our team and
everybody that works with us and it
would have been a lot more difficult to
to gather these people together back in
in Lillington you know or even fuqua
right
I need that's just that's just exactly
matters the nature of things now when we
shot the opening to commercial Kings
in the middle of the street in downtown
Fuquay Varina a block from where our
studio was like literally in the center
turn lane while people were driving on
either side of the road we had a tripod
and like a jib set up for that shot you
can't do that out here without spending
a lot of money and getting a lot of cops
to show up and signing a lot of papers
and then spending even more money as we
were you remember this when we were
shooting that we looked over there cops
did show up we didn't ask any permission
and then we walk over to the cop Fuquay
cop who shows up it was like okay we got
to apologize and plead our case before
we could get because we're in the turn
lane basically yes before that not on a
median in the road yeah for for 20
minutes oh yeah trying to get the shot
we wanted without permission so we go
over to him and we're like preparing our
statement and before we can get in a
word in edgewise he says hey guys my
son's a big fan how long you guys gonna
be here like he wanted his son to come
out and meet us which is great and then
there was like a county commissioner who
town the town Commissioner Commissioner
he rolled down the window he's like hey
hey guys I'm the town commissioner
anything you guys need just let me know
so there's that you know let's ignore
the fact that you're creating a traffic
hazard at the moment so that you know
you there's something about home there's
something about North Carolina there's
something about the South that you can't
recreate out here I acknowledge that you
know there's a lot of different elements
about the people that we grew up with
and the place we grew up that you you
can't recreate out here in Los Angeles
but you know I spent over 30 years there
so did you and it's not okay well this
is a new season and I'm not saying that
we're gonna eventually get tired of smog
and traffic and shallow people but I do
think that at least for the indefinite
future we're in a place where we feel
like we're able to do what we do to the
best of our ability because of where
we're at
yeah and I will say a mattress
oh yeah second part of the question I'll
say a stuffed Shamu from SeaWorld here's
another question hey guys this is Josh
Sundquist my question is a lot of times
people talk about how having kids
changes everything
and I'm wondering if when you look at
your videos now versus before having
kids if you see any difference in the
content that you produce very calming
voice feel like he's leading me in a
mindful meditation as he asked as he
asked the question which which he does
on his channel right so you can check
those out if you want some guided
mindful meditation from Josh Sundquist
which we didn't talk with him about on
the air biscuit so that's a little
shoutout having kids changes everything
well that's true but specifically would
quite with a question of you know our
videos now versus before having kids we
had kids before we started making videos
I mean before we started making videos
as we do now yeah under specially on
YouTube yeah I mean the first breakout
video as many of you probably know is
when we did put my stroller where your
son Locke and my daughter Lily were in
the double stroller that we pimped out
and turn into like something kind of
like the Batmobile with ground effects
in spinners I mean we have made a few
videos and you know in college we
knowledge we have made some videos but
none that like translated and broke out
on YouTube wants YouTube became a thing
and we were writing more funny songs
much more than we were making videos so
that doesn't really I think it's more
about since there is no before-and-after
there's really a this is the situation
we have children they watch our videos
how does that make it differs in the
content we produce mm-hmm
I would say that
we have not yet made a video I'm not
saying that like we're about to make
something different but we haven't made
a video that I don't let my kids watch
yeah and we think about that a lot like
I think about my kids watching our
videos and I want them to be able to
watch our videos I mean we certainly
have friends in the industry who their
kids can't see the stuff that they make
because it's you know it's comedy for an
older audience or whatever well and you
know everybody has a different standard
too because I would say that you know a
couple of times a year we'll release
something you know whether it's an
episode of good mythical morning or
whether it's a certain guest we might
have on good mythical morning or whether
it's a music video that it takes things
in a certain direction where people who
have a different standard for what they
allow their kids to watch will complain
this usually happens on Facebook it
seems that the most vocal crowd when it
comes to this particular standards they
think our video should be up to kind of
find their voice on Facebook and for
every person who has said I can't
believe that you guys did that or said
that I'm not gonna let my kids watch
anymore
I've always honestly thought well I'll
let my kids watch it I mean I wouldn't
have made it if I wouldn't let my kids
watch it right so and there's an
upcoming sketch that we're gonna release
them on our Channel
the camping sketch is there's like
implied nudity well from me and it's
like I'm gonna let my kids watch that
but they're gonna use I mean implied
nudity means that we know that you're
naked but you don't see that you're
naked I mean I mean I'm technically
naked there's implied nudity under my
underwear right now I mean any nakedness
that is in the video is covered up so
therefore it's the same as having pants
on right well if the pants were a blur
Tobler what's the difference between
jeans and blur really if you think about
it well that's is this is a conversation
I'm gonna be having with my kids when
the video comes out but I will say cuz
because they're gonna watch it and
they're gonna be a little embarrassed
but they're gonna laugh they're gonna
think it's ridiculous and it's fine yeah
and me I mean I'm not again
I'm not you know we're obviously the
majority the stuff that we create is
family-friendly regardless of what your
standard is but there are people who are
super sensitive about a lot of things
and we're not here to please those
people and we're gonna disappoint those
people from time to time and that's just
that's just part of the deal
I do want but but we do it there is a
standard of I want my kids to watch what
I do right but our kids are getting old
they're getting older so what if when
our kids are like 18 is it gonna get
r-rated at that point yeah I don't know
no it's not I doubt it but we're not
making stuff for preschoolers no we're
not it's not there have been people
who've thought that it's not for kids
but kids can watch it that's what we
always say however your biscuits in
particular is definitely not for kids
and when there's an episode that we
think is definitely not for kids we let
people know so I think it depends on the
the property speaking of kids my kids
don't listen to your biscuits that's
we're not that's what I'm saying
yeah but the only air biscuit that any
of my kids listen to
stanwyk it was snappy cat who submitted
a question for us here oh that's a great
segue hello rhett and Link this is
stamping and my question is because you
create most of your content as a
partnership what is the best and worst
thing about making videos with someone
else
compared to making them by yourself hmm
that voice is absolutely amazing there's
absolutely no reason to doubt why he has
has made himself famous it's that voice
if you could talk like that we'd be we'd
be twice better off twice as big hmm so
what's the best and worst thing about
making content together versus making it
by yourself I mean so we'll answer that
and you know I'll start by saying we've
met we've never made anything apart
really I mean you made a cup you you
made a couple of videos for Jessie like
there YouTube you're going there we
don't have to talk about that was I'd
actually don't even know what you're
talking about
I think you made a video for Jessie it
is like I didn't help you make it it was
like an anniversary video I don't know
if it was just a picture mine oh yeah I
mean I know and I've written
I've written some songs and stuff I
wrote her a song back in the early
marriage when I was really romantic were
you blowing your hair blow-dry are you
trying to go r-rated already just
because I'm just because I mentioned
were you but I was not blow-drying my
hair in the video or in the song that I
wrote Wow okay but the only thing but
all of our creative endeavors have been
done together it's like the only thing
that we the only thing that we've ever
done kind of on our own is just the jobs
that we that we did before we had
creative jobs okay but I haven't
answered to the best worst thing about
content I think the best thing in the
worst thing are the same thing and that
is you have to take somebody else's
opinion into account
I mean it's plain aside you have to get
buy-in on anything creative from you if
I'm pitching and vice versa we both have
to be on board can be one of the most
frustrating things if you have an idea
that you think is incredible or you have
a perspective on something that you're
like no this is gonna work and it's just
like if you would just let me do it but
then the best part of that is because
you want it to be easy you just want to
pitch your idea or I want to pitch my
idea and then just there not to be any
resistance so it's frustrating and it's
not even actually resistance it's part
of the process but you the problem is
when you interpret it as resistance and
it is frustrating but what we have found
is although it can be a frustrating
process it does almost always lead to a
better product because two minds are
better than one
it's a refining lesson you can get too
many cooks in the kitchen without a
doubt but we're basically the the you
know when it comes to the core ideas you
can finish this sentence if I worked
alone blank well this is kind of get
this kind of gets into
almost like an accountability thing
which is yeah if I worked alone I would
probably have taken some sick days a lot
of sick days like when I work for the
engineering firm that I worked for back
in the day if I woke up with a slightest
sore throat you were out it I called in
sick I was like this isn't worth it this
job is not fun
I feel bad I'm going to stay home and
watch The Price is Right and eat some
chicken noodle soup because that's my
prerogative but I haven't seen the
prices right since we've started this
business because Drew Carey hosts I
heard about that he's lost a lot of
weight he looks very different
not funny anymore I haven't watched um
but the thing is just to keep the
accountability intact is there's no sick
days like I honestly cannot remember a
sick day we've taken some days off for
family we've taken some days off for
vacation
I cannot remember not coming to work in
the past nine years since this business
started well it's interesting because I
was sick and I have been sick a lot I
come to work because I know you're gonna
be there and if I don't come to work I
have to come be like we gotta get we
gotta work we I'm not gonna be like I
want to go and like do crafts today
we've mutually committed to stuff but
still if there's any time that we we do
everything absolutely equal I mean if we
if you get X amount of dollars I get X
amount of dollars if you well that's
what you think if you if you take if
you're taking this amount of vacation
I'm taking this on vacation if I got to
do this well you know it's funny because
sometimes if it's like hey man I need my
computer's busted I need a new one it's
like we have this conversation today I'm
like my computer's not working well I I
think it's a justified purchased to get
a new one but I'm mentioning this to you
because I know that you're gonna die
gift that means you get one too and you
I need you to be a little excited about
it and of course you're gonna be excited
because anything that you can get you're
gonna get excited about but it's the
other way if you were to ask me there's
a chance I may be like nah let's wait
man well you know any of your kind of
getting into some of those issues that I
think that Hank Green's question oh yeah
okay raises - so let's say let's the
we're kind of getting into that so let's
let let's play
hi this is Hank green of Hank and John
Green of the vlogbrothers I wanted to
ask rhettandlink a question hi guys hi
there's something super powerful about
two people leading a creative project
together you see this a lot though it's
usually sibling siblings that are doing
it but you guys are pretty close to
siblings often closer than siblings I'd
say and also I think it requires a
really deep level of trust and
understanding to do this kind of thing
together and that is difficult to get
outside of actual family relationships
but I'm interested in building that with
other people in my life who aren't in my
family so what do you think it is about
this kind of relationship that increases
the odds of success and how have you
guys cultivated that trust and
understanding in your creative and
personal and professional relationship
that's my question
bye guys good question well you know the
first part of that question of like you
know what about that kind of
relationship increases the odds of
success I think we kind of got into that
which is this - two minds are better
than one especially when they work
together well and that kind of thing but
this thing about trust which is you know
this is something and not being siblings
I think is you know where he's coming
from yeah well and I would say for all
intents and purposes we are and maybe
even we always describe ourselves as an
old married couple
it's probably a better description than
two brothers because we made the
decision to be friends and we have met
continue to make the decision to
continue to be friends and be business
partners and but the trust thing is you
know thankfully and I and I think this
is a key Trust is something that we've
never had to work on we don't have to
work on our trust the trust is not
something that is in jeopardy and never
has been in jeopardy and I think that is
just a result of the time and a track
record knowing each other since we were
kids and we never violated each other's
trust that now we've pissed each other
off again we're gonna get into talking
about that later but we've never
violated each other's trust yeah I mean
Trust is not something that you can
enjoy
near you know it's it's interesting that
Hank said he's interested in cultivating
relationships of trust and collaboration
that don't involve being someone's being
siblings now I ain't you know he's you
know he's married and I'm sure he gets
the vibe of commitment and you know
earning trust so I'm not telling him
anything he doesn't already know in that
sense but that mean that's what our
experience is is that it's something
that we just we earned over time of not
you know just not doing something to
just really undermine our French and
that's why I get the computer when you
get the computer I mean that you know
that's it's because I'm never even
though I could you know I have access to
the to the corporate checking account to
the same degree that you do I could be
going to the ATM and pulling out cash
and you would never look at it we don't
you know but we know that that's not
going to happen and that's I mean I
couldn't we couldn't do what we do if a
trust was something that was in the
balance right and IIIi think a good
example is the the principle of adopting
the language of we when we're saying
anything outwardly we made a decision
there was actually I can't we may have
talked about this in your biscuit at one
point but we made a decision at some
point where we actually said that we are
going to not take personal credit for
things instead we are going to refer to
even if there's something that very
specifically was just one person because
we divide up more and more creatively
all the time and we know certain things
that one of us is doing and the other
ones not having much of a hand in it we
have a creative hand in everything that
we do we both touch everything but if
you're doing 90% of something like a
whole bunch of the writing on something
well we still make a decision that when
we when we talk about that outwardly
it's a we
we terminology we made this when we did
this when we created this when we wrote
this I know I think that's just a
decision to protect just to protect
against competition and credit or an ego
to protect against ego exactly right
that it's and and to say hey you know
this is our agreement this is an
extension of trust that we you know
there's something more important than
one of us getting credit are getting
more accolades than the other person and
that's us creating what we want to see
in a vision well because I think I'm
together I mean how many times have you
heard about creative partnerships or
what people would describe as a creative
partnership and it turns out that the
parties in that partnership one of them
or both of them consider themselves to
be the key or to be or no I was I wasn't
want to started this and and then I
brought you along or you know and those
partnerships always end right and like
the Linda McCartney example if you look
at the credits on any of every single
one of their songs Linda McCartney Linda
McCartney I mean they didn't all right
all of the songs and you know but then
they broke out right or was it that
Linden got shot I mean they broke up
yeah they broke up but I'm talking as
the Beatles but yeah we could still
break up but then that would be a new
agreement did is bust the analogy
basically said well no as the Beatles
but they went to India and things got
weird maybe we just got let's just not
only don't go to India
but as the Beatles and I could be a
little wrong about this but every song
whether one of them wrote it or the
other one wrote it it's credited to both
of them Lin and slash McCartney and
they're in they're both still alive and
both still best friends to this day
that's what that it would be a perfect
analogy if that was the case so just
let's just believe trade that's the case
imagine a world where John Lennon is
still living in his Paul McCartney's
best friend well then what about all
those wings songs that are pretty
awesome you've missed my imagine Joe I
know I got it oh you didn't even laugh
at it yeah I mean you didn't
appreciate it at all okay so Hank I hope
that helps did we give Hank his uh his
due well I think that I think the
application is if you wanted to build
this kind of trust with other people
then it's just gonna be it's a time it's
time you know it just it's a it's an
investment and there are some choices
you can make
and there was this quick commitment I
mean even the blood oath that we took in
I mean when was that you know it it
depends on when we're telling it when it
was really nice cause II at this point I
think it was early high school but we
made a blood oath and it was yeah it was
a it was a ridiculous thing a mother was
very broad but it was very broad but it
was the fact that we did that and then
we talked about it was it we were very
commitment-oriented you know it was and
then when we moved out here at you know
I mentioned earlier about writing a TV
pilot and when you talk to agents and
stuff like that they're asking you
questions like well what is it you want
to you guys want to do do you want to
have a network television show let's see
if we can make something happen do you
guys want and they would all ask the
question do you guys want to go out on
audition separately and we made a
decision we had we actually had to talk
about it again just to kind of renew
that vow so to speak that no we're gonna
beat it it's it's too complicated we're
gonna be in everything well yeah I don't
do oh I don't think there was never a
serious consideration that we would do
things individually no no no there never
was but when people would ask we would
have to we would have to tell them you
know and we would have to take a stand
it's like no I don't want I don't want
to see any opportunities that's not
something for us as a comedic duo that's
one of us individually you're not to
mention I mean the you know I'm not
saying that you know when we're 70 years
old if you're if you're like I really
want to open up a wood shop or something
like that I don't know if that's you
kind of want to do that then I'm gonna
be like I'm not you know well don't do
that without me but there's so many
things that we want to do as a duo that
we've yet to do the
that any any personal creative projects
that we that we want to do I think
they're going to be after we've done
everything that we wanted to do together
in it and there may never be anything
else so but I can see that there's a
time when there be something we're like
I got this little side project you got
this little side project kind of thing
but not until we do those things that
we've got a list you know it's not it's
it's it's a it's a pretty long list of
those things that we've always said that
we want to do and we're pre we haven't
made a lot of progress into that list
and we are yeah it's I think that the
the things that we want to do in the way
that I'll just make a prediction here
and I'll it's funny because I've I
thought about this like you know back in
middle school being sick like thinking
about The Fresh Prince in DJ Jazzy Jeff
okay this is gonna get a little like
geeky my kids are watching that show
right now you know we were like super
into their music and then Will Smith has
this television show
jazzy just shows up and he's a horrible
actor in The Fresh Prince of bel-air and
then Will Smith becomes this amazing
blockbuster actor yeah he's an actor
that's right
like Muhammad Ali and he was in that
independence movie and then a lot of
other stuff and I don't know what he's
up to now there's like Scientology going
on and I'm just careful again yeah right
but he'll make a comeback but Jazzy Jeff
just got into producing and his music
and I don't think that will happen to us
because I don't think we're I don't
think I just don't think we're that much
different we're not as different as
those two guys right yeah and plus there
is this pattern that you have these big
ideas then you convince to me how great
it is and then I like double down on it
and that's and then so that's kind of a
pattern that will probably a path it
works well so I think we're pretty safe
in saying that you know what about
Outkast though I mean you know Big Boi
and Andre I just think they're more
different than we are we want to break
in here for a quick moment to mention
this episode sponsor Credit Karma Rhett
what's the most
number in your life my age nope my IQ
nope the level that apart my Carlin in
the mini leveled parking garage at the
outlets nope I'll give you a hint it has
a huge impact on your finances what you
might pay for your credit card interest
home and auto loans in student debt
it's your credit score and it's crucial
to know what that score is and how it
works I knew you were gonna say that
because I know that our sponsor is
Credit Karma I was just playing a long
link hopefully I was convincing
excellent what I like about Credit Karma
is they don't just show you a score and
send you away they actually break it
down so you can see how your actions can
affect your score and they do all of
this for free and then they send you
away no they don't even send you away
you can just thing go away after you get
the helpful information don't pay for
your credit score is the point with
Credit Karma you can get your credit
score right now absolutely free just go
to creditkarma.com slash rhett and Link
to get started
you also get free tips and suggestions
to help you manage your credit free
credit monitoring and free alerts when
your score changes
there's no catch people you don't have
to put in your credit card number or
anything like that everything on their
site is free that's right Credit Karma
offers report scores and tools all for
free one of the pathways to achieving
the good life is to make sure you're on
top of your credit score go to
creditkarma.com that's karma with K of
course / rhett and Link creditkarma.com
/ rhett and Link to get started
today's episode is also brought to you
by Z via Z V is the naturally sweetened
soda with no sugar no calories and it's
also non-gmo project verified Z via is
available in 15 delicious flavors
including cream soda black cherry cola
ginger ale
orange and even tonic water all with
zero calories and all of them are
awesome especially great well that's
your favorite yeah I like the cream soda
I'm partial to cream soda but if you
love soda and you don't love the
artificial sweeteners and calories that
come along with it and you're gonna want
to stock up on some Ziva they're the
first brand to offer zero calorie sodas
with no artificial sweeteners and no
sugar and they're also certified vegan
gluten free and kosher kosher you have
to do that and stretching a little bit
go to Z Viacom / podcast because Z via
is giving away thousands of free
six packs y'all you never know you could
come home to a surprise soda on your
doorstep you know you like the sound of
that head to Z Viacom / podcast to get
yours
it's ze VI a.com slash podcast now back
to the biscuit let me play another
question here who's next
Oh Hannah oh guy in a heart Rhett what's
your favorite part about working with
link link what's your favorite part
about working with red rhett and Link
what's your favorite part about working
with the impossibly awesome Stevie when
Levine the vine Stevie
where's working with Stevie I think it's
Levine okay Hannah's friends with Stevie
so she got I guess she was still in a
shout out there but I also think the
thing that was at work there is Hannah
is trying to create some sort of
awkwardness in getting us to say sweet
things about each other because that's I
think that's her ploy here well I think
I mean you know I think that maybe she's
just a curious cat but there's an
interesting thing and you were telling
me that Jessie told you about this so
maybe you should tell it about the
awkwardness amongst guy friends - even
men are not willing to acknowledge that
they are friends with each other
Yeah right but there's like just there's
awkwardness in even saying we're friends
so for us - on a show in a dimly lit
room just the two of us to be then
doesn't wanting I don't like to think of
it as just the two of us I like to think
about the people who are also Lissa
didn't picture them being here to turn
around and say our favorite things about
each other at least she said our
favorite things about working working on
each other so it's not like I love the
way that your eyebrows dance when you
speak well that's not on my list about
you but I've got I've got some things I
think I might have a couple of things
linked I think I might have more than
one thing okay you'll go first then but
we're not gonna make eye contact while
you're saying I would say and this may
be a little I mean this may be me saying
something that it because it benefits me
and that's why I like it you're hedging
alright as opposed to just being a
good-hearted guy who's just seeing
something in someone okay is uh the it
is very and I could I think I take it
for granted having someone who when it
comes down to a perspective on something
like a perspective on a person that we
meet for instance a person that we hang
out with or a situation where we go into
a room and we have a meeting with like
five people me and you may differ on our
approach to different things a lot but
we almost always have the same exact
read on six major situations and
individual people so much so that it's
kind of like we already know what we're
thinking collectively we just have to
talk to somebody else about it does that
make sense having someone who I think
like you know I'm saying I say I'm
saying I take it for granted
that one of the things that is is I
think this goes back to us being able to
work together you know and I'm saying I
think like you and you think like me
we're very different but there's just
this whole large slice of the pie of
life that we kind of silently and
wordlessly kind of interpret in the same
way that I kind of take it for granted
until I like to start trying to have a
conversation with somebody else so
that's one thing I'd say the second
thing is one of the reasons why we work
together so well which is I don't like
to finish things and I don't like to get
into the weeds on things and I have a
tendency because you've kind of just
done this to be like it's like once we
get into like a really complicated like
edit or something like that I'm just
like I'm just kind of guy I'm just gonna
kind of go on autopilot now because I
know that link is gonna worry about this
tonight to to the nth degree and land it
and so
I mean if we were if we were the same in
that way then it wouldn't work so the
fact that you take things and you know
put your focus on them I just kind of
step back I appreciate that
yeah and I think mine well thank you for
that right I appreciate that
I appreciate that you appreciate that
about me I I think mine kind of
dovetails with that in terms of how we
creatively compliment one another
because I think my first thing that I
like about working with you is that
you're an ideas driven mind like it's
all about big ideas and the next idea
and a new idea like when we were driving
home last night
carpooling back to our homes and we're
just spitballing about kind of plot
points in some in some narrative thing
that would be cool to do you said you
throughout it you threw out a specific
idea and I was like that's a good I
thought that's a good idea my question
was did you just come up with that and
you really yeah I was I was I look out
the window and I saw that and then I
thought about this and then I said this
and it was just an idea and I was like
that's pretty amazing you know so I
appreciate that that the pressure is a
little bit off if I can say all right
this is the structure of something and
then if we only had that thing to fit
into the structure like here's a here's
a beautiful seat for a race car if there
was like something that could just sit
in that or I don't you know it just kind
of fits so it kind of takes the pressure
off me because of in that particular
sense so I appreciate that I I also
think this is a little this is more
personality maybe this kind of dovetails
are kind of business stuff but I
appreciate the fact and I mean I'm
indeed in dangerous territory state
saying this know from an ego perspective
I don't want to stroke your ego too much
but I'll just come out and say it and
then I'll backtrack a whole botch
afternoons okay you're you're usually
right about everything just gonna say
all right okay
like I'm gonna write that down you're
right about a lot of stuff like when in
doubt he's probably right about it and
it's not and I'm not really talking
about like creative decisions where it's
like really subjective and it's just
like do you like this brush stroke or
not it's more like on that painting we
did together I'm thinking I'm talking
more along the lines of like facts and
decisions and like if you actually have
to think something through or to kind of
like a have some sort of applied wisdom
I'm I'm happy to defer or if like I
don't know I and like I would just defer
to you and then I would be pretty
confident you're gonna say the right
thing or or have the right opinion or
enough of it then I can just make the
last percentage points come together and
make sense so I feel like that frees me
up I feel like I'm freed up to be wrong
about a lot of things there's a lot of
fun there's a lot of fun in that and you
even see that in good mythical morning
or in good mythical more if you ever see
a cut in good mythical more it's because
I get way too loose because I just feel
like I can say anything I want I we can
just fix it later
somehow or you'll just you'll nip it in
the bud kind of a thing so I enjoy that
I enjoyed the freedom of its kind of
like having a net so to speak Brett the
net did Rhett the net did that make
things awkward enough Hannah are you
happy with that well we all seem to say
what we appreciate about favorite part
about working with Stevie and I think
for me that's pretty easy it's the fact
that she and I guess we needed to
qualify whoo-hoo stevie is Stevie is our
psychic advisor that's right and no
she's uh what is she
head of production what is development
what is this girl and I mean it's in she
she's a lot more than that too and
that's her title but she's been very
instrumental in the growth of our team
in our in our business and I think that
one of the one of the reasons why is
because she cares you know and I think
that's my favorite thing about her is
that she will lose sleep over something
that isn't right about something we're
doing yeah like it's and that's very
difficult to get somebody's if it's her
content right good way yeah because I
know most people you know when I worked
for Black & Veatch back in the day I
didn't care I didn't know who black or
Veatch were and I in and I didn't care
about them
oh well sure it wasn't black and Veitch
and that's black and beige it's like a
dish it was all the checks I read the
checks a lot but I didn't lose sleep
when something wasn't going right at
work and and I realized that's a
difference a different scenario I was a
big company but she cares and she it she
really cares and she gets legitimately
upset when there's something that's not
right sometimes I call her at 3:00 a.m.
to make sure she's losing sleep about
stuff and she's not I'm like I'm making
you right now lose sleep and that makes
you feel better and we I mean and we've
had to actually you know fire her a few
times we've had to say you know like you
know we we got to get you you know we
got to get you some help on some of this
stuff so you'd say you don't because she
has a tendency to just take on so many
different things well I mean she
supervises a team works we said is a
great team we're not gonna Brown no
Stevie anymore or our team but I think
that we've we've we're very appreciative
yes to her and to everybody's
everybody's work alright so let's move
on to another question here Joe Bereta
hey rhett and Link it's me Joe Bereta
the secret former third member of rhett
and Link remember when you killed me by
drowning me in the pond and the remote
area of your north carolina property if
I recall it was just a success was
starting to rear its ugly head I'm
pretty sure I saw dollar signs in your
eyes as darkness assured me into my
watery grave
good times anyways we all know that you
guys are best buds but I want you to
regale us with the store
Riis of when you were truly mad at one
another what happened how did you handle
it and how did you make up cool thanks
guys I will be haunting your kin for an
eternity okay yeah so uh all right it's
out we we murdered Joe Bereta he did and
he's back and he's a ghost he's now a
ghost but he asked a good question about
he wants to get us to dish the dirt on
us fighting with each other and okay
we've racked our brains about this I you
know there's over the years when there's
been different ways that we fought with
each other I mean there's when you're
kids we didn't really fight much as kids
you were just like no so I'm not coming
to your sleepover and that didn't even
happen
we did we didn't even get into arguments
as a kid no chance no it was but in in
college we would by the time we were
college age we would fight with each
other we were like we were like
roughhouse like in in high school but I
don't know why it happened in college it
seems like more of a high school thing
that we would like wrestle with each
other well I think some explanation is
is warranted here I mean we were
watching MMA remember that I mean a lot
that was a lot of it I recall we started
watching MMA and then we would like
wrestle with each other like with it we
would have our dorm room door open and
we would be like wrestling with a chick
he would walk by and be like what are
those guys doing
and then sometimes Greg or somebody
would come over and and they would join
in yeah and you would buddy was like
amateur wrestling yeah because like 1955
or something but there was like it was
it was pent-up aggression and I think it
was just hey you know it's kind of like
how a big brother punches his little
brother we would just kind of fight with
each other because we're we're in each
other's space so much you just start
wrestling a little bit I mean I remember
it differently than that I don't
remember it being this ain't like we
would just be like arguing and then it
would turn into wrestling no no it
wouldn't
I think it was a subconscious thing yeah
you just thought it was fun but you
would also
I'm dead move witches you know you Wade
it's how much more than me sixty pounds
more than me easily and then you would
we be wrestling and it would you know it
might start was like a little arm
wrestle but then by the end you would be
laying on me full body you better I'm
dead and you just go that's a movement
that's the MMA moves dead move I
couldn't get out from underneath the
weight of like you're six seven frame
and you were skinny God but so was I and
it was but and that would just it would
be fun up in at that point but then when
you would start be like I'm dead and I
couldn't get out from underneath you and
you would be a really man up rush me
I was starting to get actually mad yeah
we get me and you could tell I got mad
because I would start a man I would
start punching you I would do things
that were like not a not part of the
rulebook but not like punching me in the
face I wouldn't bother I thought you
were just white you just playin I never
knew your accent man but I would you
couldn't see the look on my face I was
just part of a part of the character I
was not going into it like I was not
going into like a pro wrestling persona
like the sulking guy with the red face
who's like angry that was not like Pro
Wrestling I'm sorry that was me be mad
we haven't done that a long time I don't
think laver ever will but there is I do
that of my kids now though I'm dead you
still do that yeah and it get so mad I
know they get mad but but but you were
doing it at one time and I remember the
door our dorm room door was open because
it was you know it was just it's just
something happens but actually it was a
little bit the dorm room room was
cracked it looked like we might have
meant for it to be closed but it was a
little bit open and somebody walked by
and like and we were just in boxer
shorts yeah totally totally ridiculous
the more I think about this and I'm like
got you in this like hold and somebody
walks by and it kind of like cracks the
door open I remember freezing and I
could sense the door was one it was it
was grant grant and he was like okay and
just kept walking slowly walked away
yeah we didn't realize until like a
little bit later like oh that was yeah I
don't know what he thought about that
you may have drawn some conclusions
but but that I mean that I think that's
how we fall in college and then there's
like fighting over like did you take the
trash out or did you steal my ice cream
but I say these are the thing we've been
really open about is the fact that we
fight a lot I mean we argue a lot and it
does get personal and it does get heated
and I think that's a part of any healthy
friendship we don't have to get into
that we talked about that quite a bit in
a number of podcasts in the past but but
it's more of a creative thing I think we
kind of hit on if I'm gonna say anything
about it it's that there's there's
comfort that comes from creative
energies colliding in a way that makes
good things but it does get frustrating
when you think you've got it figured out
and you encounter what feels like
opposition which turns out to be a
refining force now that we don't get we
don't get mad at each other like when we
go surfing together for instance like
it's usually when we're like working
well but hold on now that you mention
that I remember you getting mad at me
when we went surfing because I my level
of hearing wasn't to your standard like
you would be like talking to me and I'd
be like what and you'd be like I I'm not
gonna yell there's like other surfers I
want you to hear I don't want everyone
else to hear I wasn't mad I was
frustrated yeah okay yeah and that was
kind of like you're like what and I'm
like what I hear I can't hear ya but I
don't want to like me I've had a
conversation with you I don't want it to
be conversation with every surfer out
here and so I'm the I'm the bad guy just
because I can't hit maybe you were
talking quietly and you just don't know
it why am I the one that's wrong or
today was not wrong right or wrong
wedding we're walking to lunch and like
we're taught we're having a conversation
you know I said in the middle of the
conversation you're like slow down well
I brought you walking well so [ __ ] this
is that's actually something I've been
meaning to tell you for a lot love for a
long time it's like I you walk from
point A to point B you walk so fast well
I was hungry no no but no no no it's
what wit whenever wherever you never you
never stroll
you are a be lying you are right to the
next thing and it's just like my wife
always complains about how I'm gonna
walking too fast she's like
I'm in high heels and your legs are so
long slow down so I always feel like I'm
gonna really slow for my wife but
whenever I'm walking with you I feel
like I'm like gum it I'm going so fast
but you should celebrate and my legs are
so long that I'm having to take these
large steps like why is he in such a
hurry so likely word is having a
conversation I was like slow down a
second but you were but you were mad no
I wasn't mad I was I mean and then and
that's and that's where the real
conflict comes from when I'm like why
are you mad I'm just walking and you're
like I'm not mad and I'm like what you
sound mad it's like I'm just talking I'm
like well why you gotta sound so mad
when you're just talking and that's said
then we have an argument about how we're
having an argument like you know merica
because you because you want me to say
like could you could you please slow
down a little bit you're not gonna
respond to that you've made it very
clear over the past 35 years or Alvar
long we've known each other that you
will not respond to could you just slow
down a little but we fight because again
like I'm backtracking from my compliment
earlier that it's like backtracking
you're right about a lot of things yes I
was walking fast but it's like the line
in the big lebowski and I've told you
this before
where the Big Lebowski tells Walter he's
like you're not wrong Walter you're just
an you're not you're not it and I'll go
on record and say that but we fight
because I will interpret what you're
saying as if you are an a-hole and I'll
say like why are you mad about me
walking fast why is it why I'm and I
think I said this day I'm like why is my
speed the thing that's wrong why can't
it be your speed that's wrong in the way
that you said it and so like I'll start
harping on like how you said something
and then you'll harp on the truth of
what you said cuz I cuz I cuz and it's
like the conversation is missing each
other
that's conflict because the first thing
that comes to mind when you ask that
question why is it that your speed is
wrong and my speed is right is because
and this is how my brain works I think
because I feel like I have a barometer
for my speed base
my interactions with everyone else on
the planet including my wife and so I
think to myself I know that I walk
faster than the average person so link
definitely is walking too fast therefore
I need to say something to him about it
it's funny that we when we were deciding
what order we're gonna answer these
questions in we were like I don't have
we don't have anything about fight and
then we just came up with two of them
because we know that we fight on a
weekly we do it all the time
and it doesn't matter you know I think
that's the point is that we're not
actually like this seems pretty heated
just for the record if any you're
concerned out there there's absolutely I
going tell you right now every thirteen
to seventeen year old person listening
right now is concerned and thinks that
that was a big fight I've learned that I
have learned that through YouTube
comments but and you know what I'm
thinking such a degree and and as we've
been talking about this fight I've been
thinking man we're really onto something
this is great like I love talking about
this and I and I I just think I think
it's hilarious and sorry to generalize
you thirteen to seventeen year olds most
of you thought that was a fight and it's
not all of you and sorry to kill you
back in the day joe bereta yeah but if
you want to see as like the cusp or the
beginning of an actual fight in a video
like a for reals fight it that does
exist what is the name of that video
killing rets beard yeah it's called
killing rats beardless when Linc shaved
my beard on episode of good mythical
morning at the end the wheel lands on a
black spot we had a secret spot at the
time and if it landed on that spot we
had to do something bad to each other
and that was a surprise surprise and
that one was slap each other and we
slapped each other simultaneously and I
thought that you slapped me too hard and
so I immediately slapped you back but I
had kind of a like it was kind of a like
come on you're like I was mad but I was
still kind of I was still kind of
smiling but as soon as I did that I
don't lie you were not you were smiling
to cover up the fact that you were mad
oh no I got no I was mad I was totally
mad but I was in my mind I was thinking
I'm gonna
hit you again to like make it even but
all that it was that just slapped me
back and we hit each other pretty hard
no punching and it immediately stops and
goes then Ted and bang pound whatever
how is it used to end back then back in
the day there was no good mythical more
but we sat there and argued with each
other yelled at each other for a good
five minutes after that while JC JC just
said they're like six feet away he Jason
was stuck in a room with us for two
years he was sat there for a lot of just
you know a lot of arguments and that
explains why he doesn't work for us
anymore by his own volition he's you
know he's doing great things he's doing
but yeah well you can see the fire in
our eyes and I but watching it back like
wash it back today and I'm like you know
what I love the comedic timing of that
like you guys funny yeah could not have
loved it could not have made it it was
worth it we couldn't have planned it
more perfectly the way that it like the
timing of it escalated so perfectly
people thought they were really mad at
each other because we were so that was a
legit mad at each other Joe and we did
reconcile we always do right along let's
get to a deep question this is shaycarl
Butler recording a voice memo in his
garage for the ear biscuits podcast
download it for free on iTunes with
rhett and Link alright so I have been
asked to ask a question to the ask
Meister's themselves and I feel like
this is supposed to be a semi serious
question right question mark we're not
looking for pirates verse Dinges here am
i correct right I assume so so here we
go
if he does or she or it or whatever it
is out there that is bigger than us and
that created us and hopefully loves us
and cares for us if that thing exists
and in the next 20 years there's
technology that also exists that makes
it possible for us to transcend death as
we know it to literally overcome the
problem that our species has
face for its entire existence we don't
die anymore because robots go into our
bodies and our consciousness is that big
word that is us inside our bodies is
able to live forever inside these robots
that we create can both of those things
exist that end god and if so what does
God think about that does he want us to
put robots in our body or does he not
want to that's my question - rhett and
Link
alright thanks I'm Shay Carl follow me
on Twitter it's a [ __ ] Carl and then you
can watch my fun family vlogs at
youtube.com slash Shaytards okay guys
looking forward to your answer bye bye
you're kidding me I love it
who else can go from such an intricate
question which seems like it was kind of
like on top of his head still which is
kind of crazy to like a just slo-mo self
promo so quickly well it's interesting
that it sounds as if he asked that
question from the gates of heaven yeah
but I think it was his garage that he
has the question I think he was onstage
at the Mormon Tabernacle okay so you
know this question we you know he called
us the ask my skirt Meister's I think
the implication there is that we've
asked a lot of difficult questions here
at this table including Touche so Touche
yeah we will we grilled him for two
hours we will receive a difficult
question from Shang yeah now it's okay
so Wow well this is there's a long
question it was there's a lot to it but
I think that okay so to summarize a
question it the question is if we're
able to take human consciousness and put
it onto or into a robot let's just say
into a hard drive you know to get it to
leave the human body can that scenario
and God exist at the same time and if so
what does God think about that so it's
it's basically like if that
movie transcendence where Johnny Depp
uploaded himself to a computer and then
he like to the Internet
if that were possible what would that
what would that mean what would be the
implications and what would what would
God think about that um you know first
of all as a movie it wasn't the best
employee ever it was I want you know and
I watched that movie on the plane and it
was the audio was real bad and I could
hear a little bit of the movie that the
person was watching next to me I was
like a short in the headphones why does
that always happen on a plane no that
was that was Johnny Depp good I know but
I'm not trying to dodge this question so
let's answer it interestingly this
raises another question which is kind of
what Shea's getting at I think and that
is let's just say if we are able to take
human consciousness and we are able to
implant that on to a robot like a hard
drive basically what yeah let's say
there's a computer there's a hard drive
on a robot but let's just say that we
also have the technology to create a
robot that physically looks like a
person let's just make this personal
let's say that we're able to figure out
how to get your consciousness onto a
robot that looks exactly like you like
it's such a good recreation that I can't
even tell the difference physically
between you and this this robot well
first of all lucky robot second second
thing is well I'm not dead yet so let's
just that's kind of irrelevant in one
sense I think no one no I'm just saying
it I would feel I want I want I feel
like that's not me anymore but let's say
I am dead well but let me let me finish
the let me finish the full scenario and
let's say that we get to a point
technology wise that I am able to take
or scientist whoever are able to take
your consciousness in your brain and
implant it onto that you that looks
exactly like you mm-hmm so not only does
it look like you but
consciousness that you have in your
brain goes into this and then I being
your best friend for most of your life
I'm able to interact with that second
link your wife is able to interact with
that second link and after spending a
certain amount of time with second link
I cannot tell a significant or I can't
tell any difference between link number
1 and link number 2 and your wife cannot
tell any discernable difference between
link number 1 and link number 2 I think
so much so that you just start calling
it link I could just call it link okay
yes the implication would be that your
consciousness everything that is you was
something that was biological /
electrical right it was completely
contained in the material world and it
was able to transfer over to another
being another robot that would raise a
lot of interesting questions that's
right big if but let's say yes that
happened well but let's say that okay
but the other scenario is we transfer
that consciousness over to link number 2
and during my interactions with link
number 2 I think to myself you know what
he seems to have the right answers to
some of my questions and he seems to
remember some of the things that we did
but he's walking slower
he seems soulless there seems to be
something missing or if Christie were to
say there seems to be something missing
then maybe what that thing that is
missing would be would be what people
would call a spirit or soul but let's
just say for instance because he just
because I think Shea's the question is
what if it did transfer perfectly could
that scenario exist like Christie can't
tell the difference I can't tell the
difference it seems like the full link
has transferred but I could tell a
difference I feel like I would tell a
difference like if I weren't dead yet
and be like don't don't interact with
that link number two I'm over here man
but that link number two would feel
exactly the same way as link number 1 or
link number two was like in a computer
monitor and he wasn't in the body yet he
want to get out he would have it
theoretically if there was a perfect
transfer he mad if you want if there was
a perfect transfer then he would have
the I would be miss same sense of self
that link number one had and what and
what and what if he did and what if he
did well well first I want to I feel I
want to I feel a desire just say that
that wouldn't happen but I don't believe
that it's possible I just I
I'm just seen on animo even just an
emotion love if I were just isolate my
emotion or emotional reaction to that
right now that I don't I don't want it
to be true on emotionally you're making
it personal but I guess I made it
personal what if it was your what if it
was someone who didn't know what if it
was a stranger but I think if it's a if
this is just a person if it's a perfect
simulation is that just is that a not a
statement about God or spirituality at
all it's just a statement about
technology well if it I'll tell you I
mean if I don't know if that it you know
I mean who's to say that we would even
have the technology to even entertain
this question although there are people
like you know the futurists or reycarts
well whatever his name is who basically
says oh this is gonna happen in 2045
which presumably is within our lifetime
I think that it would have implications
right because if if that were to happen
if you were able to take a whole of a
person and put them on a hard drive then
kind of what you're saying is that if
you can take a quote-unquote soul and
put it on a hard drive then it probably
can't pass into another dimension it
can't go to heaven or whatever you know
so I think it would have some
implications in terms of what people
think about the world but I don't
necessarily think that it would have
implications about God in particular and
it could to answer Shea's question can
God exists and that scenario exists at
the same time I don't see why not
but it
we definitely have some implications
about the way we think about the spirit
soul body that kind of thing
you have to make some adjustments yeah
yeah it's interesting because I just
don't know how I would feel because I
keep going about back to how I feel
which is not the maybe not the operative
question here but I so to put that aside
for a second I I do think I know this
I'd like for I'd like for somebody to
pursue it like I'm not singing outlaw it
is controversial I'm saying go for it
scientist well because because what all
we're gonna do is learn I mean don't as
long as that doesn't mean you're gonna
suck the life out you're gonna kill
somebody in order to throw them on a
hard drive as long as you're not doing
that so he's not hurting anybody I'm
saying what are we afraid of with you
you know what are we afraid of finding
out let's let's see what we can find
let's see what happened well I would
like to think that I am open-minded
enough to have my worldview be adjusted
by a discovery like that I mean I think
anyone who would say that I'm not
willing to to follow that result
wherever it might lead is just saying I
don't want to hear something that's
contrary to what I already think so if
somebody could also confirm what you
already it could you know it could so
what are you afraid of you know not you
personally but don't be afraid don't be
afraid that's how I feel right all right
I'm completely on the same page now do I
do that I'm worried about myself being
digitally cloned perfectly the point
where I'm not special anymore that wigs
me out but do it to somebody else and
tell me tell me what happens I'm very
curious about that so go for it
I mean Jay I guess Shea's doing this out
in Idaho yeah I think his voice is why I
moved back he's freaking out there and
Idaho's gosh when he asked this question
sounds massive is probably a massive
yeah Ricky
multiple Shaye's right he's growing
other shades and he wants to know what
God thinks about it don't ask us ask God
hey man that was that was that was fun
though I'm I'm I feel like stupid and
like I'm wigging out all of a sudden
thanks for asking that question
I hope that's not how we make other
people feel for your biscuits here's
another question this one this one goes
really deep hey Rhett hey link it's
Harley from Epic Meal Time I sure as
hell can't be the only person that wants
to know the answer to this question here
it is have you ever seen each other's
penis when oh good why why not have you
ever bathed together well he went for it
I wrote that question for him yeah I'm
sure you know I didn't mean Harley is
talking about comedic timing that was
delivery well I just go ahead and say as
you can probably already tell by the
fact that this question was included we
did not rule out any questions if you
sent a question in the audio we let you
ask it early asked about whether or not
we had seen each other's penis and what
when why and why not the answer is yes
let me just start by saying this and let
me and let me qualify that answer by
saying that if you're if you're best
friends with somebody for as long as
we've been best friends and you don't at
least accidentally see the other guy's
penis at least a dozen times then
there's probably something wrong so but
it's like a fleeting it's like I'm just
like it's like a it's like a frame of a
movie
I've probably seen your penis a dozen
times but I've probably seen it for a
total of definitely less than 12 seconds
because I've never dwelt upon it
I mean it's been alike well there it is
that was an act you know we've we've
been in hot tubs with naked naked older
men in the middle of the desert it like
the hot springs out in Death Valley
we've done that two years in a row we've
been we've skinny dipped in the with our
good friend Mike up in the top of a
mountain and and and Southern California
we the National Forest the water was
cold and we laid out on hot rocks like
reptiles for like 30 minutes and went to
sleep
we skinny dip only naked in high school
we skinny dipped in the he feels he
feels pond in the Cape Fear River yes
I've seen your penis you've seen my peen
there's a whole group of people involved
we don't make a big deal about it
it's it's just two guys that have
happened to be naked at the same time a
number of times but like I said I've
never made an effort to see it now I
will say that I have never seen your
penis I've looked and I just totally
true I'm gonna refrain from making for
making jokes any comebacks at all I knew
I was gonna say that like five minutes
ago I was just waiting for you to shut
up so I could say that stupid joke I
remember specific instance though this
is a middle school experience you know
when when like everything's awkward you
probably don't tell me if you remember
this it was the first time that like you
would go to the beach with your family
every year but it was first time like
you were invited me and like I went to
the beach with you and your family and I
what beach was Topsail you would go
there every year and it was like those
of those summer winds and when summer
went yeah yeah mm ah summer winds condos
and I remember one night like we you had
a room it had two single beds and it's I
you know we were sitting on the edge of
our single beds like getting ready to go
to sleep and you know when you're a
middle school sight we're gonna stay up
and talking so we were just like sitting
around
hanging out in our boxers and a t-shirt
just kind of like talking about middle
school crap like I don't know Ninja
Turtles or who knows what and I I
remember I was having a cut I was
talking to you about I don't know it
could have been Ninja Turtles I don't
know it could have been injured Turtles
and I remember at a certain point in
conversation you were like that was like
it was extremely embarrassing I remember
I don't know why it was I mean it was
just the way it was I was I was like you
know there's not like a zipper on the
boxers and it's not a big deal or
anything I was just looking out for you
I mean I wasn't I wasn't embarrassed
yeah it was just a weird thing but it's
like one of those things when you're I
don't know 12 years old and I was like
oh I wonder if he's still gonna be my
friend after well I had my junk hanging
out of what boxers you know put it away
and I kept telling my Ninja Turtles
after I put my ninja turtle up you're
right but well you know the interesting
thing this is actually my hero in a
half-shell this is making me remember
and I think a lot of guys do this in
college we went through this phase like
probably junior year where because we
had the apartment with Tim and Greg and
you kind of go through this phase where
you're just like if I need to go I don't
know what you're about to say if I need
to go from the shower to my bedroom I'm
just gonna walk through the house naked
and I don't care which of my roommates
sees me right we all four of us did that
yeah and we just we just like we don't
care okay and there's almost this
certain sense of freedom and like
adulthood that you kind of feel in that
party over it's like usually I remember
how tame and I was in high school to be
like oh I'm in the locker room I don't
want anybody to see me I'm really scared
about this but then all of a sudden you
start growing out of that you're like oh
I understand why all the professors in
college are in the locker room
naked cuz they don't care look they're
over it
yeah like when and when you put your
butt cheeks on their back they don't
even flinch or get up or say anything or
grunt know you kind of revel in that for
a few years and so I mean again I would
I never buy for any there was never any
purposeful eye contact with their nether
regions
and I would assume that you you feel the
same way yeah but I wouldn't see that
you were naked so it would be like penis
and the periphery is sort of this sort
of that probably probably a good way to
describe it right yes which could be the
name of our next album yeah or at least
like a side band is that a pun side I
don't know well okay so Harley thanks
for that question hopefully that said Oh
have we ever bathed together no I don't
believe so we did just recently make a
video where we play I played a guinea
pig and link played a little girl we
were baby together but it was green
screen back yeah right we were fully
clothed we have one last question this
one is a secret question it says alright
here it goes hey I'm Alex Oh Maddy hi
I'm chase and I'm Kevin and we work for
you guys literally every single day and
we just had a quick question we're
wondering when we were gonna get paid
okay guys well it's gonna be a lot
longer now now that you asked that
question
yeah well we'll get back to you on that
one okay well the pranksters trying to
get in yeah that's what happens when
they have access to SD cards high
quality the highest quality audio of
recorded will probably recorded right
here at the round table of dim lighting
yeah we don't we're not paying them yeah
yeah so so that's it I you know this is
this is fun I think we could do another
round of this next time this is this is
a tradition that can continue I just
don't want to convey the question is to
get tougher and tougher so maybe it
won't continue well yeah we may have to
start we may have to start leaving some
out but we did make every effort to
answer every question to the best of our
ability thanks to everybody who
- time to ask these questions and thanks
for the time that you guys were guests
here on your biscuits and listening to
us ask you a question after question as
we teamed up on you and the things
thanks for taking the time and thanks
for taking the time to listen to your
biscuits if you know this is one of your
first ones you just got in theirs I
don't know how many that's a lot of
episodes back your biscuit season 1 and
season 2 we've had some incredible
conversations with some incredible
people I know that I have learned a lot
even if you don't think you want to
listen to one based on the description
now you got to go back and find ones and
hey we were there and I think you'll
find new things about guests that you
didn't think you wanted to listen to so
fill in the gap of us not having new ear
biscuits for you for a while and try to
keep us a part of your routine we do
appreciate you being your mythical best
tweeted us hashtag ear biscuits let us
know what you thought of this
conversation what stood out to you if
there was anything that was helpful and
feel free to tweet at all the way one of
these individuals who asked us the
question you know thanking them for
their for their question for all your
biscuits yeah thanks for being a loyal
listener and for leaving a review on on
iTunes U I'm there's a part of me that
doesn't want to take a break because I
enjoy the conversations that we have
with the guests that we have here at the
roundtable and you know it's kind of a
forced kind of a relational rejuvenation
for us I feel like it's a good thing for
us to have these type of conversations
you know where we're we reminisce we
process things a lot of people who are
guests end up saying things at the end
of our conversation or after we stopped
recording that's like yeah some people
say well if it felt like therapy and
that that's that's kind of funny but
kind of true - I guess depending on some
of the questions we asked but the thing
that I enjoy people to say is when it's
like wow you know you helped me put
things together and and get it gain a
perspective on my own life or my own
career people
verbally processed things yeah so I
appreciate the way that that's something
that a we get to share in that
processing with people and experience
that as they go back through it and if
there were eight days in a week we would
continue to do it yeah indefinitely but
the other half is just when it's the two
of us there's there's kind of we
experienced that too you know I think
it's it's nice to think back and to
process what's why things work so well
for us and what's going on our
friendship and creative collaboration
and everything so yeah I'm in the break
I'm gonna be glad to be focusing on
these other creative endeavors but I'm
gonna miss this until we get back into
it so hang in there guys listen back
through them and that's all I got to say
I'm thankful yes very very grateful to
the ear biscuit ears I'm gonna go take a
bath by myself okay please do that
[Music]
[Music]